Wearing a blue cap, face mask and work clothes,...
...a disguised Carlos Ghosn emerged Wednesday after 108 days in jail.
Eluding hundreds of reporters, he slipped away unnoticed in a small van.
Earlier, family members were seen entering the facility.
Ghosn was released on nearly 9 million dollars bail, paid in cash.
As part of the terms, he will have to surrender his passport, be monitored at home...
...and have restricted phone and computer access.
Ghosn was taken into custody in a dramatic scene last November,...
...shortly after his arrival at Tokyo's Haneda airport.
He's accused of underreporting his income by roughly 80 million dollars,...
...and using his position as CEO of Nissan for financial gain,...
...charges which carry a maximum 10 years' prison term.
He has declared himself innocent of all charges, which he termed unsubstantiated.
His release is highly unusual for Japan,...
...where white-collar defendants usually are forced to await their trials in custody.
After two previous rejections, his lawyers successfully argued for his release,...
...capitalizing on growing international criticism of Japan's criminal justice system.
However, Ghosn's chances of acquittal remain unclear.
Last year, Japan's conviction rate was about 98%.
Lucy Craft, CBS News, Tokyo.